Porta body is right over there all right
there's been a lot of talk among Dems
about misinformation and disinformation
basically any sort of information that
doesn't help a Democrat get elected also
known as the truth in the eyes of the
Dems the story of hunters abanded laptop
had to be misinformation because it
threatened Joe Biden's candidacy so they
manipulated social media to quash the
story they suspended and banned anybody
who talked about it they called it
Russian disinformation and it worked and
they got the result they wanted a reject
from a balance of nature ad in the white
house but that wasn't enough especially
now that Elon Musk has bought their
favorite toy Twitter and turned it into
something called X so now musk Must Be
Stopped enter Media Matters on Friday
they put out a report saying Nazi
content ran on the app alongside
corporate ads from major companies like
IBM app apple and Oracle and so a bunch
of companies then suspended their ads on
X but now musk is suing Media Matters
saying they manufactured the report
apparently these companies were duped
like someone who bought Girl Scout
cookies from Dylan
bany be happy that's all you
bought but before we go any further we
should clarify what Media Matters really
is in case you don't know see there this
left-wing group funded by wealthy
leftists while dishonestly positioning
themselves as an impartial media
Watchdog but the only part of that title
that's true is the dog part because they
make Chris Cuomo interviewing his
brother seem
impartial those were the days so why is
this important because the mainstream
media uses Media Matters knowing that
the public has no idea what it is and
they won't bother to check that it's a
front to silence people specifically
conservatives but there's really only
one entity that's worse than media Media
Matters it's the orbit of parasitic
blogs mediaite The Daily Beast the
independent helping toose CNN's reliable
sources who grab the Media Matters
stories add a few words to avoid
plagiarism and then repost them they lie
by telling only part of the truth you
know it's like when Joe Mackey says he
ate at a food truck and it turns out to
be an ice cream
truck this Amplified Universe of lazy
hacks feeds off One Bowl of outrage
kibble and because Fox is its Target
we've kept more clowns employed than
Baran Bailey fnc might as well cut
checks to these ass pops directly it's
kept Brian stelter floating in a sea of
Twinkies and The Daily Beast from going
back to their old jobs making lattes so
what did Media Matters do this time well
according to the lawsuit First Media
Matters went on X and followed a small
subset of users from one of two
categories those who post Fringe content
and bigname advertisers then they kept
refreshing the hand selected feed until
it got the result that it wanted
controversial content next to paid posts
from X's largest
advertisers then they took screenshots
of it claimed it was organic and
published an article about it and this
quickly panicked the Cowardly
advertisers including IBM Apple Disney
Wonder Brothers and Paramount and so
they fled like women when Keith Oberman
asked for
number it's worth pointing out that some
real journalist Michael shellenberger
and his team at public tried to
replicate Media Matters research and
they couldn't so these advertisers fell
for the ruse because they're too scared
and lazy to take a stand those company
stockholders should be pissed and those
companies should be embarrassed for
pulling their ads based on madeup horse
if you acted on what Media Matters told
you you should be fired taking
directions from them on anything related
to speech is like learning to freestyle
rap from Joe
Biden so now musk is hitting Media
Matters with quote a thermonuclear
lawsuit for the fraudulent attack but
that's not all Texas Attorney General
Ken Paxton's opening an investigation
saying he's extremely troubled by these
allegations and Missouri attorney
general Andrew Bailey is also joining
the fight promising musk he's
investigating Media Matters as well so
why is this important because Media
Matters is a hard-left smear machine yet
it's one coddled by the Press who used
that content to build their own crap you
may not have heard of Media Matters
until today but you can bet your liberal
Pals read their stuff regularly since
CNN hacks like stelter and Oliver Darcy
rely on their fod they simply called the
outfit a watchdog group Media Matters
became their necessary but brain damaged
henchmen a stupid careless brute that
does the Dirty Work that these lazy saps
won't do so Media Matters assuming they
could get away with with it went after
the richest most capable man on Earth
one with deeper Pockets than most
countries but like Hamas they went too
far and now you see the hacks circling
the wagons so why did Media Matters go
after musk in the first place because
he's a threat by caring only about the
freedom of the press which is exposing
how vile these leftists are so they need
to take them out right now leftists are
taking to the streets of America a
chanting anti-semitic hate tearing down
posters of Jewish hostages mainstream
media repeats the lies of H while second
guessing everything Israel says and does
when Jews are being barricaded inside
College classrooms I don't see any Trump
hats if anybody's acting like Nazis it's
the left I.E Media Matters own team so
they're doing what Nazis do meaning
they'll do anything to destroy an enemy
even when what they call the enemy is
actually their own country so I am so
here for this and you should be too
because it's about time somebody exposes
Media Matters until they don't matter
anymore and although I'm no legal
scholar my money is on the guy who
builds Rockets not
lies welcome tonight's
guest just like cranberry sauce he
retains the shape of his container
comedian Joe
Mackey her play byplay will make your
day out kick host Charlie
Arnold nothing to him is off limits
except maybe a barber comedian and
author of that joke isn't funny anymore
LZ and finally I think he Once Sold me a
set of encyclopedias Fox News
contributor Tom
shaloo Joe excellent choice of outerwear
That's a
classic uh members only jacket is it not
than it is Greg it's uh they don't just
sell these anyone you have to be pretty
hot and cool and relevant you actually
have to be a member don't you you have
have a member to own that they won't
just sell it to anyone no they won't I
want to read you a question that was
written for me by one of the writers uh
Joe do you think if Media Matters tried
to cancel you maybe one or two people
might come to your
shows W uh I did not write that well if
if they do cancel me Greg I hope that
they mention in the article that I'm for
me at the St Louis Funny Bone November
24th through
26th
but I'll tell you what medium matters is
Fen the same old liberal script it's not
the first time someone's done this the
CDC uh laundered information for the
teachers union Stanford launder
information for the Department of homand
Security with their election Integrity
partnership it's a brilliant idea and I
use it when I used to be when I used to
be a player yeah like I would have my
wingman say something to the ladies to
impress them and it wouldn't come from
me and sound like I was bragging but
I'll tell you what it backfired why
because the last thing women want to
hear from one of my male friends is the
phrase take it for me Joe Mackey is
great at
[Laughter]
[Applause]
sex so you say you used to be a player I
guess this those days are behind me
Greg
so you have a twitch okay Charlie are
were you before you started doing Fox
were you aware of Media Matters did you
know what they did yeah I would see I
would see their name in different
Publications I would never pay too much
attention to it because it was just
often quoted like you mentioned there's
so many different news outlets that'll
take their information maybe attribute
them maybe just add a couple of extra
words but since getting here Greg I have
personally been victimized by Media
Matters on multiple occasions as I'm
sure you have as well I think they have
a dossier of me going back to 2007 yeah
it it's constant uh but like you said
anything that they deem that will not
help their cause is labeled as miss or
disinformation and I think that Elon
Musk knows this all too well which is
the reason why he purchased Twitter now
known as X in the very first place he
wanted to restore free speech and I
think that from the GetGo we saw School
Ms in the government in uh Society uh
from all different walks of life
attacking him instantly yeah and we're
seeing the same script being you know
taken out at this very uh stage in in
his ownership and it's really sad but at
least Ken Paxton and some other attorney
generals are at least trying to
investigate Media Matters to turn the
tides if you will but I will say that
conservatives there's one thing they are
used to and that's losing they've been
losing a lot of things recently that's
their basic Liberties Free Speech being
one of them uh they're losing their
country to illegals they're losing their
government to Communists uh they're
losing culture to the filth of society
uh so something needs to stop the skid
and I hope like you mentioned that it's
El thermonuclear attack mhm one day Joe
you will lose your
virginity Greg you
can't I couldn't resist it it's a jacket
Lou I am very excited over this because
this dude H is the richest man on earth
so he's just going to run Media Matters
into the ground I would hope well I mean
I mean he did say
thermonuclear and he is a rocket guy as
you as you talked about uh ear so you
know I just hope that I'm here next week
because if things blow up that much it
might be a little nuts but it is
interesting um because I I noticed the
trend when I was on X anytime I would
put in white genocide I would see an ad
for blue chew which I don't know if you
guys are familiar with it's like the
it's like the updated Calis right you
know so it's like oh obviously a Nazi
would want you know you know something
to help them uh take care of business in
order to you know repopulate the Earth
so
it worked that's all I'm saying yeah it
worked there you go Media Matters it
worked you got me man I have less
respect for the people that use Media
Matters than Media Matters you know what
I mean at least they like they they
might have an office that they go to but
everybody that uses Media Matters are
just lazy hacks would you ever think
about like there's an agent right now
from Media Matters assigned to you oh
definitely every single thing that you
do like he's going through your garbage
you know anything that he can find
what's a Verbatim on their site like
they will listen to your whole segment
everything that came out of your mouth
will be verbatim that's because that's
not I mean if it's not out of con
verbatim is better than what's the
opposite twisting your words yes yes
exactly so I don't mind I I I actually
don't mind it when people take my words
it's just that they will put it within
something else to make it sound like you
did something different I don't know Lou
nothing yeah um actually I might have to
rewrite this whole segment to put
different words into my mouth to make me
sound a lot better than I do right now
Tommy as the whitest guy I
know do you mind appearing uh against uh
next to uh controversial stuff you know
uh Media Matters has a dossier on me as
well Greg yes it's not as long as yours
but when I do show up in it and you know
I just feel loved I'm like oh you guys
still I still matter to you I think it's
great uh but Media Matters has been
committing fraud every morning for the
past 15 years I mean that's the way they
do business and you're right it's the
lazy journalists who write their press
releases verbatim and you know they're
the ones that are really to blame it's
like you know it used to be that people
would lie in politics the rules of
politics when you're running against
someone you can lie and people like oh
well he's a politician he can lie so
they would hire these opposition
research firms do their dirty work for
them Media Matters is an opposition
research form firm for the entire right
right and the media is playing that game
it used to be the media would they would
kind of call balls and Strikes right but
now the media covering politics goes by
the rules of a political campaign yeah
exactly they're constantly campaigning
yes and they have one and they have one
go-to and that's Media Matters so they
so they don't even have to get out of
bed it's they waiting for them on their
laptop and then they just dress up put a
headline on it and they send it out yeah
and you know once it's in the Press then
we end up talking about it so we end up
talking about stories on this panel that
Media Matters created they created a
false Story New York Times prints it and
then they're talking about an MSNBC and
it's like oh now we have to talk about
it so we're actually addressing it it's
it all it really works very pernicious
Greg there you go an endorsement from
Tom Shalo you know what tomorrow's story
is going to be Greg what Greg gut F fat
James big boned
riter
yeah yeah that is not body
inclusive I hope that's the
case that's good up next libs are
shaking in their socks cuz Trump's
healthy as an a hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else